[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
on today's show we're talking about
trauma and the lie that men are only
worth what they accomplish and achieve
we'll also be talking to a woman who's
dealing with a lying husband
who kind of treats her like his mom stay
tuned
hey good folks i'm john and once again
this is the dr john deloney show
caller driven show about you for
you by you where we're talking about
life we're talking about relationships
we're talking about relation
like you mental health parenting
moving or the family member
who way way over shares
on social media about their pets
nobody cares about i don't know what
kind of carpet they get nobody cares
oh my gosh about this funny thing that
they saw
nobody cares here's the deal some things
we've got to learn to keep
to our selves right
and i guess all we have is all we have
in our power in those moments is the
thumbs down so everybody thumbs down it
right don't do that because other people
can be calling the show talking about
what do i do and everyone thumbs down my
cat poster whatever so anyway if you
want somebody to hear you if you want a
second opinion
you want advice worth the price you are
paying for it give me a call i'm here to
walk with you
my number is one eight four four six
nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one eight
four four six nine
three thirty two ninety one or you can
email me at ask
john ramsey solutions dot com i tell you
what we are getting emails
by the truckload i guess they're coming
digitally there's no trucks but they're
coming from all over the world
i'm getting uh instant messages from all
over
planet earth it's it's been wild and
it's been exciting i want to thank
everybody for subscribing to the show
and for joining us
both on the show and just listening in
your car
or while you're mowing the lawn or
whatever so it's exciting times
appreciate it give me a call
1-844-693-3291
let's go straight to the phones let's go
to josh
in montana brother josh what is going on
how can i help man
hello dr d happy to be getting your
guidance here
to start my question is at what point
and i know you're not going to endorse
it but at what point does divorce become
viable or how hard should you work in a
marriage
oh that's a great question so one i
would tell you
there are times when i endorse it um
they're rare i'm pretty high on marriage
but
there are moments i endorse it so walk
me through what's going on in your
particular world
so i disagree with divorce too i was
married once before
in 2009 august 2009 i actually got
struck by an ied in afghanistan
took some major damage to my back and
during my deployment
my year in the hospital and the about a
year after
i found out that that spouse had been
cheating on me the whole time so we got
divorced
yeah i got custody of my kids i moved
out to wyoming
and i ended up getting married in 2018
and i know that
from my time to service and my healing
process i
became a very strongly independent proud
person who wasn't really emotionally
extremely available so i know i wasn't
there for
my current wife as much as i should have
been in her depressive states
and the drinking took hold on her she's
just very aggressive drinker and
gets very mean and it went to the point
where
in february my three kids were sleeping
in the back
and our child that is about five months
old at the time
i was holding him and she ended up
grabbing a pistol out of my room and
chambering around and i had
relieved her of the pistol and honestly
i called the police
but it's just i don't know if i can
go back to trusting her or seeing her in
my heart or my mind the way i did
and i do recognize that i personally
was not man enough to break down with
and for her
man so there's a lot there brother um
let me back up and start with you
what is your healing journey been like
um i went through quite a bit of
counseling due to anger because i was an
infantry man that was my dream job that
was my world
right and i i lost everything i was
retired at 21
and i was just angry at the world i went
through many counselors
none that seemed to click and i didn't
want to be on any medication
right so that's where the independence
strength came from is i just
kind of wanted i tried to heal myself
okay and
so i kind of just fed it into my family
and myself and
just became a very singular person
so walk walk everybody listening through
the back end of that
right and your response dude is
honorable i get it i understand it
particularly when
you're coming from a a a rigorous
military training that says there is a
solution to every problem if you will
follow these steps
and when you're going to see a counselor
it tends to be amorphous and tell me
what's going on and how you're feeling
and if there's not a plan or steps right
it's it's easy to
say this this sucks this isn't effective
i'm just tired of talking about things
nothing's getting better and then to
really take the bull by the horns right
and i
will solve this problem and i will do it
through grit and determination and work
and power and strength so you're on the
other side of that now
i can hear in your voice both directly
and
auditory right that you're feeling some
cracks in that solution
tell me about that i just
i'm still not really sure how to
become that man that i should have been
this entire time been more emotionally
available
instead of just you know pay toughen up
kind of guy
okay um and i know that i need to
personally get help anyways even if
if the marriage does not work out i know
i need help just so that i can still be
more available for for everybody around
me my kids and everything because
like i said i got custody of my kids
right and
so i want to be more available for
everybody but i'm not really sure
like i said i don't know if i can see
her that way or if we should try
marriage counseling or
so i want to acknowledge and if no
counselor has done this shame on them
but number one i want to acknowledge
you and your service okay but i also
want to acknowledge when people
say that out loud that that comes as a
mixed blessing for someone in your
situation
okay and i know that you are trained to
say thank you very much i appreciate
that and i also want you to know that
i understand that comes with a burden uh
that idea of service
number two you've got trauma
everywhere around you and what that
means is your brain has been trained
because somebody blew you up
right you were trained to
to you were trained as an inter inter
infantryman right you were trained on
how to
disarm and how to hurt and kill other
people
that's what you were trained to do you
have trained your brain to be scanning
your environment at all times
and then you gave your heart to somebody
and she cheated on you in really a
super super vulnerable moment for you
right so that's a relational trauma so
i want you to back up 30 000 feet
and exhale for a second and i want you
to look at what your brain is doing on
your behalf
every person around you has been
weaponized
those who love you those who are against
you
those who even put things underground
that you're just gonna be walking along
on the sidewalk and will get you
right and that's what your brain has
been trained to do because of life
circumstances
and i want you to know that that sucks
and i hate that for you
because the only way the only way
you find peace and you find the ability
to exhale deeply
and walk through life with a little bit
lighter load and a little bit more joy
is through connecting with other people
and right now your brain has weaponized
that for you
understandably so right
and then that brings you to number two
you find somebody else to fall in love
with you probably went into that guarded
appropriately so understandably so right
that's not a blame statement that's just
an is statement
um and you went into that situation
unguarded she probably has her own
challenges and own frustrations and own
baggage with that as well
and then dude so one of the moments i
would tell you you got to really be
careful and i'm glad you are
is when people are not safe and when
they're chambering guns
for those of you who don't know that's
somebody put a bullet in a gun was she
going to take your life her life
somebody else's life what was her what
was her intentions there
she was back to me her back was to me
she was facing the other direction when
i had heard it and turned around
it was pointed up in the air she stated
that she had no intention of harming
anybody
it was a suicidal showing to
grab my attention okay all right and so
dude you did the right thing by calling
the police i
i will say it all the time my friends
and family the closest people to me the
ones i love the most i do not mess
around with
suicidal ideation suicide intention
suicidal threats whatever you want to
call them
i've just done too many funerals i've
been to too many funerals i've
officiated too many memorial services
i'm done with that right so
good for you for calling in the calvary
and now you're the smoke is clearing and
you're wondering what to do next
so my my first question to you is do you
love this woman and do you want to spend
the rest of your life with her
i absolutely love her uh obviously my
intention was to spend the rest of my
life with her
i'm just having a hard time inside my
heart and in my mind
with trusting her you know like
leaving her alone with my kids and i
don't know if i can get past all that
right do you understand where that
lack of trust is coming from number one
she pulled a gun out in home
right so that's number one and she
loaded it up number two
your brain has been for lack of better
terms i hate using
mechanized uh metaphors here or computer
metaphors but your brain is now wired to
think that everybody's out to get
everybody you got that
yes okay and so i can hear
her situation as she is so desperate to
connect with you
so desperate to connect with you that
she is willing to go out to the edge of
the earth to try to get your attention
so desperate to hear a vulnerable
connected
i want to get to know the josh beneath
the alarm systems that are going off 24
7 365.
now the way she chose to do that dude is
dangerous it's not safe and if my kids
are in that house i'd be freaked out and
worried too
if you love this woman and she is
otherwise stable she is otherwise
not doesn't threaten violence doesn't
commit violence doesn't hurt anybody
i would double down triple down
quadruple down both on marriage
counseling yes
and on your own healing
and i hate the fact i hate the fact that
you have not found somebody that works
with you what you need
desperately is both trauma counseling
because you've been through it
all over the place and more importantly
dude you need a group of men
not soldiers you know what they could be
soldiers i take that back they could be
you need a group of men you can be
vulnerable with because you've got to
learn the skills the same as you learn
to shoot a rifle
the same as you learn to do pull-ups you
have to learn the skills of being
vulnerable
and i'm telling you josh from a guy who
loves you that is the only way
to stop the alarms is with other people
that's it and you can muscle and grit
your way to
six pack of abs you can muscle and grit
your way to being successful at a job
you can dope yourself up so you sleep
you can muscle and grit your way through
the quote-unquote right things to be in
relationship with somebody to be a dad
but they will always feel that gap
between you
because you're not able to be fully
vulnerable and i'm gonna tell you dude
i'm not a combat veteran in any way
i am no way i am in no way
a i've been through anything like you've
been through
um but i will tell you i had to learn
how to be vulnerable i had to learn how
to connect
so when you hear the word vulnerability
and connection what do you hear
be honest with everybody listening what
do you hear
weak weakness yeah
where does that where does that
definition come from
actually that's rooted back to my
childhood okay
men are tough they don't cry they don't
talk about being sad or anything like
that that they're supposed to be
the rock for the family
with it shows no stressful or strainful
emotion
in front of the family and so josh
i'm just now meeting you for the first
time today we've talked for 10 or 15
minutes
there is no greater lie on planet earth
than what you just said
that is an out in out disturbing
disgusting damaging evil lie
which i've i've kind of you know i'm not
exactly like that anymore i was for a
very long time and
i've been working on this on my own and
it's been a long slow process i mean
it's been since 2009 that all this
went down but it's slow progress
and i just every time that we would have
an issue you know the guards went back
up and i was
is like i regress that's well brother
that i mean your brain is doing what
it's designed to do which is to protect
you and get you to tomorrow
right and it's almost lost you a few
times right i mean it's doing what it's
supposed to do
um and so there's going to be some
moments during the day probably every
day for a season
do yourself a favor when you feel that
guard go up when you feel
your shoulders tense up and you feel
your hands clench
just smile and say hey brain thanks i
got this
thank you cause it's just trying to love
you man it's just trying to love you
and get you to the next day and get your
next day because the sidewalk underneath
your feet blew up you know what i mean
you got to understand that trauma in
your brain there is no calendar and no
clock
and so the woman you pledged yourself to
that you had kids with
she betrayed you so boom people who love
me are enemies
you were raised as a young boy to
understand that connection is weakness
and so everything that keeps a human
being well
was taken from you as a young boy and by
the way that definition of masculinity
is nonsense and trash and it hurts
millions and millions and millions of
millions people across the world
it's a cancer on our society because
you've got feelings and you've got
emotions and we are trained to shove
them
down you know what another word for
shove down is depress
to cram it down that's what that is
brother and i hate the fact that
that that we're all of us i'm the same
boat man
that's the way we were trained to get
through life it sucks
so back to your wife man if you love her
and you want to spend the rest of your
life with her
and you think in your heart this is
worth doubling down on
then i say 100 go for it now that
doesn't mean that you're not smart
you're not safe
if she threatens your kids if she
threatens her life if she threatens you
yeah dude i'm taking my kids out and we
can do our work
um at a distance but i'm going to keep
my kids safe no question about that
if she had a bad night and she didn't
threaten anybody
and she was just trying to do whatever
she could to get your attention
then i think you're real safe about the
guns and you're real safe about the
ammunition
and you are really direct with her
about her role in guns and damage moving
forward
and again hear me say i'm a texan i grew
up around guns i grew up around
ammunition there may be some people in
other parts of the country listen to
this podcast
that are just their mouths are open
thinking i'm crazy um
i have a uh they're more of a part of my
life growing up my dad was a homicide
detective
they were just around and so they
weren't a big taboo thing
so you are going to know that best for
anybody in your heart and mind
i tend to be more like you like you said
i tend to be more relational i want to i
want to make things work but i want to
make them work safe
and here's the other thing dude do you
hear me josh i want you to hear this
directly okay
yes sir here's what i want you to start
doing today
well how old uh back up how old are your
kids
i got a uh well now 11 year old
nine year old and a year old oh man
dude so you are back in it right
yes you got uh one of those joyful gifts
a decade later right yeah very cool
he's my little buddy that's awesome so
do me this favor and i want you to
i'm gonna give you a pass for your
family okay i want you to tell them that
you talked to some quack on the radio
just some knuckle-headed dude that you
found and on a podcast
and he told you to do this thing today
is um
i want you to mark the day on the
calendar whatever day you decide to
start this
i'm gonna recommend today and every
morning
i want you to go find each one of your
kids and i want you to put one
hold one of their hands and put the
other hand on their face
okay and i want you to look them in the
eye i want you to tell them
i'm your dad and i love you and i'm so
glad that the god of the universe gave
you to me as your kid and i want you
just to sit there for a
beat of a second and then i want you to
go find the next kid and do that okay
i want you that every day in the morning
and every day in the evening before
bedtime
under no circumstances do you miss that
time the second thing i want you to do
is i want you to get with your wife and
every morning
i want you to hold both of her hands and
look her in the eye and say
what does our picture of today look like
and when she tells you well i gotta do
this and i gotta do this i gotta do this
i want you to say thank you for sharing
me that and at the end of every day
i want you to look her in the eye and
hold both of her hands and say dude i
know this is ridiculous some
knuckle-headed guy on the radio made me
do this
i want you to say how is today in the
first few days she'll say fine and you
say nope find's not a good answer you
gotta actually tell me
and if she says well the guy at work
sucks and this thing i want you to not
try to solve the problem
not try to fix the problem i want you to
look her in the eye and say
thank you so much for sharing with me
that sucks that was awesome
i love you and that's it because here's
the deal
the way you have been trained since you
were zero years old
through high school through an excellent
military career
through rehab through relational
distress
the way you have been trained josh is
that you are only valuable when you
accomplish
and achieve and i'm calling it bs times
100 on that
you are valuable and you are worthy
because you exist you have dignity
because you are just a human being
you have value and intrinsic worth
because you are you
and you've done some awesome stuff on
top of that stuff you gave
part of your body for me and our country
and i'm grateful for that but that
doesn't define you
what defines you is that you're worthy
of love
and you've got to learn to not try to
solve your wife's problems
not try to i just got to cram all this
advice into my kids no no no man
those are folks to be with those are
folks to love and then the third and
final thing i want you to do josh is i
want you to go
not give up i want you to find a trauma
counselor
i want you to find someone who is an
expert in trauma counseling whether
that's
emdr or brain spotting or somebody who
can modify
a trauma focus cognitive behavioral tf
cbt
for an adult somebody who is skilled and
that may be outside the va
that may mean you got to go take another
job and earn some extra money
but i want you to go do the sessions to
heal from
a lifelong trauma challenge but
especially the stuff that you dealt with
in the military especially your stuff
you dealt with with a wife who betrayed
you josh i love you man and i'm
so grateful for your call if you are
safe and your kids are safe don't give
up on this marriage
you're worth it your kids are worth it
and my guess is you love her enough that
she's worth it
so man thank you so much for the call
what a saint um
after a couple of weeks of doing this i
want you to call me back i want you
emailing back
and i want you to say hey dude you're a
quack i held my kids hands and i told
them i loved them every day and all your
nonsense and i told my wife that
and that was stupid didn't work give me
two or three weeks then call me back and
if it's lame i will announce it over the
year
my friend josh that i met the veteran he
did what i asked him to do and he said
it was stupid and
it had no value i will i promise i will
commit to that but i'm almost 99.9
guaranteed
that it will work thanks brother uh man
thanks for spending a little extra time
on that call let's go to lynn in
brownsville texas
lynn how are we doing oh good sir how
are you
i'm all right uh well
uh my question is um my husband
continues to hide debt from me
and the huge debt i found out recently
i confronted him and he didn't really
say anything
and he doesn't want to pay it off
quickly like i do
and then i found out he was hiding other
that a credit card debt and he still
hasn't come come
clean about it and i haven't confronted
him yet so i'm wondering how i should
respond
wow so it's less about hiding he's just
lying to you what's what's the debt
the first one was a student loan and he
he asked me if it was okay if he got a
student loan for about seven thousand
and i didn't really want him to do it
but
he but then i was like okay that's fine
you can just do it but you have to put
in your name i'm not
doing i'm not closely and then it just
built up from there
i later found out it was 24 000 by the
time he graduated
and um and then i
found out about that because i got an
inheritance and i wanted to use that to
pay off the debt and then he kept
going around it not admitting and
finally by the end of the day he
admitted it was 24 000 it was way over
the inheritance amount
so um and then the second one
i found out that he put about 500 on a
credit card to enroll in a master's
program
and he went behind my back on that
because
he asked if he could enroll in a
master's and i said no
i think we need to pay off this other
student loan first
and i guess he enrolled in the masters
charged it to the credit card but then
backed out because
he couldn't handle it and he hasn't told
me about that one yet
what's what's the state of your marriage
outside of this this
it i work for dave ramsey as you
probably know and yeah they call it
financial infidelity what's what's the
state of your marriage outside of this
financial infidelity
um it's okay we're a blended family so
we have no children together but we've
been married 10 years
and emotionally it's pretty well i'm
actually the one that suppresses my
feelings like you're talking about
but he doesn't he's like very open with
his feelings for the most part he always
wants to talk about things
but we're just not on the same page on
debt it sounds
very maternal like you are the adult
mom in the family and he's the kid
because
i my alarm systems go off anytime
somebody says my husband came and asked
me if he could buy this
and my response was well i'm not going
to co-sign for you
the reality is y'all got a 10-year
marriage his debts your debts your debts
his debt right so you're already in on
this but
are you more the mom or his wife
yeah it feels kind of like that but we
agreed to come to each other
if we want to spend over 50 on anything
and we
discussed the budget but he kind of is
passive about it
he's like goes along with it but i'm
i've always been uh the dave rams even
before we got married
and my husband isn't doesn't agree with
all of that
like paying off debt quickly and all
that is he
is he cheated on you in other ways too
um i've found out over the years he's
lied about other things
and i wasn't aware of it in the
beginning of her marriage i guess it
just wasn't
i i've tried to look all the good things
about him
so i just kind of i didn't look into it
i wasn't skeptical then
then recently yes there's things other
things he's lied to me about in the past
has he cheated on you with other women
no
no okay so he just lies to you and and
about certain things and then spends
money that y'all agreed you wouldn't
spend
okay so here's the deal it sounds like
you've got a super immature husband
and at some point i'm gonna say you're
being immature too because at some point
you've got to draw these boundaries
and you've got to say either this is
just the guy i married
i'm not going to lose any sleep over it
i want to be like this but he doesn't
want to so so be it
or at some point you're going to have to
draw hard boundaries
and sit down and say here's who we
i want to be in our house i want to
vision together and dream together
and then you have to have this is really
uncomfortable you have to have an or
what
an or what
or you're going to have this hard
conversation and put these boundaries in
place and he's going to say
no i'm not doing that dude i want to go
to grad school again and i'm not paying
off debt i think dave ramsey's an idiot
i think delony's an idiot i don't want
to do any of those things
and you just you're gonna call it
are you gonna leave what are you gonna
do and so this
clearly is a situation that you can't
handle by yourself and i don't say that
negatively
it means you need a third party you need
a counselor of some sort
and so what i'm gonna strongly recommend
is that you tell him
hey you need to see somebody on your
head i'm gonna go see somebody
because i've got to get some practice
building boundaries i've got to get some
practice
standing up to a husband who's lying to
me all the time and
the more you find out about dishonesty
after a decade
i'm telling you right now there's going
to be more there and more there and more
there
because where a guy is lying about money
yeah yeah sure
same budget cool and then they go spend
it and not just seven thousand
and no it wasn't actually that it was
three times plus that it was twenty five
thousand dollars twenty four thousand
dollars
oh and by the way this and you find it
about more lives i promise you there's
more there
and what you need is a third party and
my gut tells me
you know that my gut tells me that deep
inside
you know something isn't right something
is a little bit
wishy-washy and i want you to get some
professional help and care
my hope is he'll go with you if he won't
if he won't go with you then that's a
bigger red flag and you're going to need
to sit with a therapist with a pastor
with somebody you trust
to walk out to kind of iron out what
next steps are going to be
and you are a blended family so my guess
is this isn't your first time
down this road my guess is that your
heart is breaking because
uh gosh i've been down this train tracks
before and i know where this leads
and so it's on you to to stick a flag in
the ground and say not this time
i'm going to double down on myself i'm
going to double down on my marriage and
you just got to be able to call it on
yourself and say i don't have the i
don't have the strength or the skill set
to do this on my own i got to get a
professional
so that's my recommendation to you lynn
let me know how that conversation goes i
want you i want to know what it's what
happens when you sit down and you look
at him and say
this stops you've been lying to me for a
decade we're going to see somebody and
we're getting
all the truth all the crap out on the
table
and then we're going to work together
i'm not your mom i am your wife
i am your partner i am your lover ew
no lover mom mixes right lin no lover
mom mixes
i am your wife not your mom we do things
together
no more permission giving no more that
nonsense yeah and let's get it on the
table let me know how that goes i'm
gonna be fascinated to find out
if he steps up or if he goes i just want
to play
i just want to play fortnite i just want
to play fortnite and go away so all
right
man we took a we took some extra time
with the first call today with josh
and i'm glad we did that guy is awesome
and our thoughts and prayers with him
with lynn
we're gonna wrap up today's show with
the song of the day
one of the greatest song no i'm not
gonna say one of the greatest band
ever it's a super group there was one
band that was awesome
easily the greatest front man of all
time no question shape
form or fashion you took the the core
group
although i'm a big zach de la roca fan
you took the core group
the the instrument gurus of rage against
the machine
you bring chris cornell he comes down
from on high in his greatest front man
of all time spaceship
and they form a super group audio slave
their 2003 record
actually the 2002 record the 2003 song
oh my goodness here we go here's the
lyrics to i am the highway
pearls and swine bereft of me long and
weary my road has been
i was lost in the cities alone in the
hills
no sorrow or pity for leaving i feel
yeah
i am not your rolling wheels i am the
highway
i am not your carpet ride get this
i am the sky chris cornell bringing the
truth
i am not your carpet ride i am the sky
and this
is the dr john dolone show